[Music]
rawr
if you're one of the world's 2.2 billion
christians wow that's a lot of people
you probably think that
around 2000 years ago here in the
nazareth mountains in the
galilee region of modern israel a man
known as jesus christ was born you
probably think of him as
the messiah the son of yahweh the god
of the jews but if you're one of the
other
five billion people on the planet you
probably just think of jesus as some
kind of
wise man who had a religious cult built
up around him
after his death or maybe you're one of
those people
who believe he never even really existed
he's just
some kind of literary myth like a
hercules or
king arthur
but whichever camp you're in i think we
can all agree that jesus is one of the
most
influential and intriguing figures in
all of world history
about 40 years ago when i was a good
little catholic boy going to sunday
school
i was taught the story of jesus it went
something like this
about 2 000 years ago a young married
woman still a virgin
was made pregnant by the god of the jews
she gave birth to a baby in a barn
and three wise men found him by
following a star
so they could worship him and give some
gold and scented oils
when he grew up jesus walked around
judea telling thousands of people he was
god
and performing miracles such as
magically making fish and bread appear
turning water into wine and raising
people from the dead
one night he told his friends to eat
some bread which was his flesh
and drink some wine which was his blood
then the jewish authorities who were
angry with him
turned him over to the romans who
actually wanted to let him go
but the jews convinced them to crucify
him but then
a few days later he rose from the dead
and told his friends that dying was
secretly the plan all along
because his death wiped out the sins of
the world
his friends wrote down what happened in
a book and started a new religion
but then the romans started persecuting
them until one day
the romans changed their minds and
decided to become christians instead
at the end of the world jesus will
return to judge the living and the dead
[Music]
to be honest when i was a little kid the
story didn't make a lot of sense to me i
remember thinking
so this dude has magical powers and he's
invisible and watching me when i sleep
at night
it all seemed a little bit creepy but as
an adult
i started learning more about the
history of early christianity
as i read the bible more carefully and
read the works of modern new testament
scholars and ancient historians
i started to realize that the sunday
school version of the jesus story
was vastly different to the story as it
appears
in the bible the actual story is far
more complicated
and far more interesting so i thought
i'd go out and interview a range of
world-renowned biblical scholars and
historians and academics and ask them to
help me
tell the story of how christianity went
from being some sort of
fringe jewish personality cult
from the backwaters of the roman empire
to a point where it was the state
religion
of that empire wielding enormous power
over the emperors themselves
so let's get back to the sunday school
version of the story
what do scholars think about how
accurate that
version is research that that was
happening at the beginning of the 20th
century
a german scholar walter bower came to
the conclusion that in fact that picture
is a very manufactured one
and it's it's not like jesus was walking
around palestine saying hi
i'm god i'm going to die for your sins
soon but until then
how can i tell you a few good cracking
sunday school stories
and then afterwards you can get down
with worshipping me um
that that may be the the basic view but
that's that's not quite what happened
so how did it happen how did that
version
become the story most of my christian
friends seem to believe
a lot of christians don't actually read
the bible and if they do read the bible
they don't read it historically they
don't read it
thinking about what the story is telling
you
about the origins of christianity they
look at this uplifting passage or that
uplifting passage
they don't compare the gospels to one
another they don't look at the really
weird
stuff so they feel like they know the
bible
but it's a very selective knowledge it's
the sort of greatest hits or you know
the most uplifting most you know
seemingly relevant stuff to the 21st
century
they're looking for a single verse that
will inspire them for their journey that
day
and that's perfectly fine there's no
criticism of that but the problem with
that approach is that you're not
actually reading the bible as it's
intended to be read
christians read bits but do they read it
systematically
well systematically but not necessarily
for historical reasons systematically
to clarify their beliefs and they just
sort of
don't get to see all the really strange
stuff
all the contradictions all the
discrepancies i mean how do you go
from being a religion that celebrates
somebody
who has died on a roman cross to
a religion that celebrates that cross
and takes that cross forward into battle
i mean that's the story of christianity
within 300 years
going from a superstition to being the
state religion that's absolutely
extraordinary and that is what
the early roman historians called it
they called it a superstition but before
we get into the story of jesus
i think we need to wind the clock back a
little bit and talk about the
world into which christianity was born
a long time ago there was a man known as
lord
redeemer savior simultaneously
fully human and fully divine the son of
god
and god the bringer of peace and
salvation
sent into the world in the form of a man
to forgive the sins of the people
[Music]
that's augustus caesar if you ask most
people living in the roman empire
right about the time jesus was born who
the son of god was
most of them would have told you it was
this guy
augustus was the adopted son of the
original jc
julius caesar the great roman general
who was stabbed to death in
44 bce after he was assassinated the
roman senate declared that he ascended
into the heavens to become a god
and augustus as his adopted son was
therefore
called dear we filius the son of the
deified it was
new to to rome because it was augustus
himself who
saw uh what he thought was the soul of
of
a part of caesar going up to the heavens
and that's why he can then claim
that he is the son the adopted son not
the natural son clearly
the son of um a divinity another title
bestowed upon augustus was
savior because he ended a hundred years
of
civil war he bought peace he brought
peace to rome he brought peace to the
empire
and then according to tradition
somewhere around the middle of the reign
of augustus jesus was born
so several decades before jesus even
appears on the scene
romans are pretty familiar with the idea
that somebody can die and become a god
or be the son of a god and the savior of
mankind
so who exactly was jesus
well it kind of depends on who you ask
some scholars believe he was an
apocalyptic preacher or a political
troublemaker
others think he was more of a wise sage
or a hippie pacifist who preached love
and brotherhood
it's a little bit strange that after 2
000 years scholars still can't agree on
exactly who jesus was
one thing they all do agree on though
jesus was a jew
[Music]
if you look at pictures of jesus in most
churches today you'll see a
white guy with long brown hair neatly
trimmed
beard blue eyes but christianity started
out as a jewish personality cult
jesus was a jew so he probably would
have looked more like
i don't know dj khaled than jared leto
he would have been a dark-skinned
brown-eyed palestinian
let's put it this way if jesus returned
and tried to board a plane in the united
states today
he'd probably get taken into a little
room and randomly screamed
and when i say jesus was a jew i don't
just mean ethnically a jew i mean
a religious jew in fact he was a very
religious jew
and so were most of the early members of
his set jesus's torah observant
peter is tor observant james is torah
observant
and paul is torah observant the torah is
the first
five books of the hebrew bible what
christians call the old testament
jesus and the guys who ran his group
after he died
peter the guy he left in charge and
james who according to tradition was one
of jesus's brothers
were jews not christians
and they weren't trying to start a new
religion
they weren't trying to reject judaism
they were just trying to
fix it jesus was not only torah
observant he actually made the law
stricter rather than looser the law says
don't commit adultery jesus says don't
think about it that's harder
the law says don't murder jesus says
don't be angry
jesus was a first century a.d
galilean jewish prophet he was a prophet
who believed that god was about to
intervene decisively in human history
and being a religious
jew in the first century must have been
pretty depressing
for hundreds of years jewish prophets
had promised that
their god yahweh really thought they
were pretty
pretty special they were his favorite
tribe
he had their back and he was going to
make sure they ruled the world
but for some reason yahweh hadn't
delivered
century after century the jews had been
invaded
and conquered in fact just a few years
after jesus was
born his homeland had finally become an
official
roman province jewish people could see
that
things were not going particularly well
things were not flourishing
they were subject to external powers
whether they be the
the greek kings the seleucid kings or
whether it
be the romans later on instead of coming
to the conclusion that their prophets
were wrong
or that yahweh had lied to them
the jews just decided they must have
disappointed him
and he was ignoring them or not
answering their prayers so anyway the
jews decided
they had to be better and make yahweh
happy with them again
but how
[Music]
the most important thing to know is that
there was no
agreed standard of what being a good jew
was in the first
century just like there are hundreds of
different versions of christianity today
and they all think that they're the
right one we know that in the first
century there were lots of different
versions of judaism
as well and they were all trying to
figure out
the magic trick to get them back into
yahweh's
good book this is a situation that is
eventually going to be rectified by god
destroy the roman oppressors you know
think end of raiders
of the lost ark for instance where the
fire comes down and burns up all the
nazis
you know that's that's probably the view
that a decent number of jews
had now some jews living in the first
century believed that
god was going to send someone to save
them
they call that person the messiah
[Music]
so how do you know who's a messiah
different people will give you different
answers and there are different
messianic candidates to follow
oh uh i'm just looking for the official
guide to knowing who the chosen one is
i'm sure it's got to be in here
somewhere
there's no messianic checklist in
judaism as if make sure your mother is a
virgin
when you're conceived walk on water
raise the dead uh
die a sacrificial death come back after
three days and ascend
some jews were expecting a shepherd
others were expecting the angel
michael still others were expecting a
priest and still others a warrior
some people thought john the baptist was
the messiah and he doesn't fit any of
those categories
we use the term messiah messiah is fine
it means anointed
it means that god has anointed this
person with oil but when you're talking
about messiah you're really talking
about
somebody who is a king in the line of
the greatest of
all the jewish kings king david and lots
of jews believed that
a king david-like figure would establish
himself in jerusalem
and he would transform israel
restore the kingdom politically was part
of that bring the people back from exile
set up the homeland again restore their
independence
drive out the foreign invader some jews
thought the messiah was going to be a
great
warrior to lead them to a military
victory
others thought he might be a charismatic
preacher
who would convince the entire world to
believe in yahweh
others they didn't think about the
messiah much at all
not all jews wanted a messiah because
normally if someone's going around
calling themselves a messiah it's going
to lead to war
war means death famine bloodshed that
type of thing so i mean
not everyone wanted a messiah not
everyone even believed in one so
there's a variety of expectations
certainly the dominant one is this
political
military figure so why is this important
well when jesus is dragged before the
roman governor of judea pontius pilate
the charges laid against him are that
he's claiming to be the christos the
christ
which is just the greek word for messiah
in other words he's
claiming to be the king of the jews
mark 15 2 pilate asked jesus
are you the king of the jews judea at
the time was
ruled by rome they didn't have a king of
their own
they had a governor who reported to the
roman emperor
tiberius caesar claiming to be the
messiah was an act of political
rebellion against rome
a modern equivalent would be declaring
you're the rightful
king of the united states
now an important thing to understand
about the jewish concept of the messiah
was that he wasn't supposed to be
divine and he wasn't going to have
magical powers
he was just going to be a regular man
they did
sometimes talk about the messiah as the
son of god but not in the later
christian sense
they meant son of god in the sense of
good israelite because all israelites
are sons of god in the adopted sense
anointed by god special to god but like
their kings
david solomon and the other
good kings yeah fully human somebody
that god has placed
on the throne to rule in his stead
but it doesn't really mean somebody who
has from all time being sitting at the
right hand of god the father it's a
different concept from that it's much
more jewish and it's much more grounded
than that
the son of god would only have
been used i think in a metaphorical
sense not not in the way that we
come to expect with christian doctrine
the early christians
took that and ran with it further it
really does remind me of how
augustus caesar was anointed to be the
adopted son of his
father julius caesar and therefore
became the son of god
you know here's an interesting thing
about jesus's name
in hebrew his name was yeshua which
basically translates as
god saves or savior and as we've already
seen
christ means messiah and the messiah was
supposed to be the savior
so jesus the christ translates as
savior the savior according to the
jewish historian
josephus there were actually quite a few
guys
who people thought might be the messiah
walking around
judea roughly around about the same time
as
jesus none of them succeeded
they all failed they were all killed
and can you really be the messiah if you
don't achieve anything
which is why the vast majority of jews
in the middle of the first century
don't follow jesus because a messiah was
not supposed to die
on a cross executed by the romans
because this is somebody who's supposed
to
lead a successful military victory uh
if you just get executed as a as a
revolutionary
in the eyes of most jews that rules you
out can't possibly be the messiah
can't be the messiah in that precise
understanding
so what they they reinterpret they
reinvent
the meaning of the word
[Music]
a crucified messiah was kind of like
fried
ice cream it's an oxymoron it's a
paradox and the messiah doesn't get
crucified
he rises up defeats the romans and
establishes a new
davidic kingdom what is that so you want
to be a messiah well the messiah
actually
okay did you kick the romans out of
judea well no not yet but they uh
have you converted the world to judaism
no i'm planning on it but you know
did you bring about world peace in your
lifetime well not yet at all but
going by you really don't have the
qualifications to be the messiah now do
you
maybe you should try carpentry i see you
have some experience in that area
next so someone came up with the idea to
pitch the concept of the messiah to the
gentiles
i've got an idea what if we market it to
gentiles
[Applause]
so what you see in early christian
writings
uh is a sort of redefinition of a
messiah
which is a pretty wacky idea when you
think about it because the whole
point of the messiah was he was supposed
to save the jews
from the gentiles not save the gentiles
a gentile is someone who isn't jewish
but of course the gentiles didn't know
that
they didn't know that the messiah was
supposed to come and defeat
them and they had already been
indoctrinated over the last
hundred years with the idea that a man
could die
and become a god so why not this jesus
guy
the greeks and romans already accepted a
whole
pantheon of gods so there was no big
deal about adding
one more especially if this one is
promising
that the end of the world is coming soon
and that people who pray to him
as a god will get the reward of eternal
paradise
something the older gods didn't promise
and who was the number one salesman for
this
new kind of messiah
the earliest references to jesus come
from the letters of the apostle paul
the new testament contains 14 letters
supposedly written by paul
but many scholars only believe seven of
those
are authentic despite his letters being
stuffed down the back of the new
testament
paul is actually the first person who
ever
wrote anything about jesus at least as
far as we know
but paul was a bit like that friend you
have who just started watching
breaking bad he was a bit late to the
party
paul never met jesus but he knew people
who knew him one of the things that
really surprised me when i
started studying christianity was that
the earliest and most prolific
writer about jesus never even
knew him never even saw him
for that matter now paul says that he
knew people who said they knew jesus
but did he really know them we've only
got his word for it
and before he joined the jesus bus paul
was a hater paul actually had letters
from the high priest that enabled him to
go and persecute
early christians the high priest was a
member of the sadducee sect of judaism
they controlled the sacrifices in the
temple and didn't believe in the
afterlife or the resurrection of the
dead
but saul began to destroy the church
going from house to house he dragged off
both men and women and put them in
prison in his own words
paul says he was beating up and
arresting christians because
paul says that to him
as a jew the idea of a crucified messiah
the messiah going getting crucified
was nonsense a few years after jesus
dies
paul goes from beating them up to
becoming their number one salesperson
why the change of heart well according
to his
own letters written in the late 40s
ce about 15 to 20 years after jesus
died the ghost of jesus appeared to paul
and told him to go preach to the
gentiles
but how do you convince a bunch of
greeks and romans to worship a dead
jew well paul came up with four
fantastic marketing ideas that continue
to resonate with billions of people
around the world to this very day
for what i received i passed on to you
as a first importance
that christ died for our sins according
to the scriptures
for paul the messiah is not really a
warrior king or a charismatic
preacher he's more of a human sacrifice
to yahweh
see paul seems to think that jesus had
to die so yahweh would forgive the human
race for
adam haven't eaten the magical piece of
fruit
now most romans in fact most people on
the planet had never even heard of
yahweh
let alone adam's act of grand theft
fruto
so it seems a little bit harsh to
sentence them to an eternity
of damnation now listen i know most
christians don't like thinking of jesus
as a human sacrifice to an angry god but
let's be honest at least on paper that's
exactly what it looks like
according to the encyclopedia britannica
human sacrifice is the offering of the
life of a human being
to a deity centuries before
paul both the jews and the romans had
replaced
human sacrifices with animal sacrifices
but he's bringing it back baby with the
greatest
sacrifice of them all not just a human
but a son of a god the best sacrifice
you can possibly have
is the superhuman sacrifice and because
it was
given that blood can save everybody
and paul doesn't stop there he's
resurrecting
more old ideas
it comes then down to the fundamental
thing for christianity
is jesus is raised from the dead
that becomes the one thing that that
makes
everything else pale into insignificance
okay
he hasn't driven the romans out of
jerusalem but god raised him from the
dead
no matter what else happens whatever
failure he was in his life
he is approved by god like human
sacrifice the idea of a resurrected
god wasn't original to paul or
christianity
now like every great marketer paul knows
how to take a negative the fact that
jesus didn't really kick the romans out
of judea before he died
and spin it into a positive he says wait
wait wait wait you don't understand he's
going to come back and then he's going
to destroy
every authority in power he's like the
terminator i'll be back
you know what's cooler than a warrior
king messiah a warrior king messiah
with super powers but not many jews
bought into the whole
super-powered messiah idea they tended
to call bs on all of that
so paul decides he needs to find a new
audience
paul's the guy that takes it to the
gentiles
[Music]
the original sect just wasn't hitting
the right market essentially and paul
figured this out
consciously or unconsciously uh and
retooled it to be successful in that
market and that's why it exploded
which i think led to the doom of the
original sect because
paul had a much bigger market to tap way
more gentiles than jews
way more gentiles who are excited by
this idea than jews would be
and so you had the churches explode in
size with gentiles
now of course in order to market judaism
to the gentiles paul needed to make some
pretty fundamental changes as far as all
of the other
early jesus worshippers were concerned
in order to join the little club you had
to either be
or become a jew but of course probably
the biggest hurdle for most gentiles in
becoming a jew was that you had to get
circumcised whether you were a child
or an adult but paulie walnut says
oh forget about it just the marketing
genius it took to get rid of that one
restriction
oh we don't have to do that sure sure
i'll become a jew yeah that's fine
i'll take on this new religion we don't
have to chop our our penis up anymore
can i interest you in a new form of
judaism
no thanks heard it all before um what if
i told you that you
don't have to chop off the end of your
knob
go on paul's type
of preaching was ideal for them oh we
can be in that
jewish trajectory but without all the
stuff we don't like
sign me up but what did the original
disciples think about all of this
well as they were torah observant jews
we can only imagine
so paul we've been hearing rumors that
you've been making up some focaccia
stories about jesus
what exactly are you telling people just
the usual stuff james
jesus was a real mensch who died for our
sins
he's coming back any day now with
superpowers yadda yadda
oh and gentiles don't need to become
jews anymore
whoa are you crazy this is a jews only
club
bubbler anyone who wants to get in needs
to lose the end of his fans
not negotiable you schmuck
peter bobby the gentiles really like
their foreskin
let them keep it oh vey the hot spot on
the schmendrick
listen up butts you know bubkus
we were his best friends james is his
brother
if he wanted to let the guy him in he
would have told us
listen i'll tell you what you do your
thing
and i'll do my thing and we'll just see
who wins
mazeldov i think a lot of jesus's
original
disciples were very suspicious of paul
he wasn't part of the original band he
didn't know jesus
and even worse than that the young paul
had persecuted the church he was
he was trying to bring down the church
so why should they trust this guy
paul doesn't really seem to care what
peter and james think
anyway he says that when he did meet
them they didn't tell him anything that
he didn't already know
he is very clear repeatedly in his
letters that he learned this his gospel
from no man
no human source whatsoever i want you to
know
brothers and sisters that the gospel i
preached is not of human origin
i did not receive it from any man nor
was i taught it
rather i received it by revelation from
jesus christ
when he does mention his sources
it's the divine it's the lord it's god
and it's the scriptures also because he
feels well i've got
every bitters right every bit as much of
a right to be called an apostle as you
all have but they said yeah but you
didn't meet jesus so
his big answer to that is to say
i did meet jesus i met him on the road
to damascus i met the resurrected jesus
paul says that the ghost of jesus told
him he could throw out a thousand years
of jewish
law and tradition but they don't seem to
believe him i mean
anyone can claim to have a revelation
and he doesn't really have a great
reputation either i mean it was only
just a few years ago that he was having
their friends arrested
and beaten up so they all seem to butt
heads
there's one story where paul and peter
have a stand-up row
a stand-up row in antioch in front of
everybody because they disagree on the
implications
of their the movement that they're part
of according to paul's
own account he started calling peter a
fraud
to his face in front of everybody
when peter came to antioch i opposed him
to his face
because it was clearly in the wrong now
peter was the first disciple that jesus
ever had can you imagine
what must have been going through his
mind when this paul guy
who never even knew jesus started
getting up in his
face in front of people unfortunately we
only have
paul's side of the story when paul's in
a
bad mood and he's in a really bad mood
in the epistle to the galatians he wants
to say
they didn't add anything to me there's
nothing that they told me
that added anything to the gospel which
i got from god
but we know that this isn't true imagine
pacing up and down a room
you know yelling you know while
someone's like taking and taking it all
down that's
that's the best way to imagine paul you
know creating galatians led to the
galatians
and at the same time but a lot of
affection and
love and care as well so i made maybe he
was bipolar i don't know
and it's not just peter and james that
paul's having a problem with at this
stage
you see even at this early phase of the
jesus
movement there seem to be a number of
different factions emerging
and just like today they all claim to be
the
one true movement so we have example of
uh
in first corinthians paul is trying to
respond to uh a letter that the
corinthians wrote him saying hey
this other apostle apollos um
came by and taught us all this other new
weird stuff what's it seems to
contradict yours what's what are we
supposed to make of this
but you'd immediately ask like who's
this apollos guy
he's not on any lists of disciples paul
calls these other missionaries
false apostles even though he's the guy
that never even knew
jesus oh the cojones on the sky
we know that in the first century there
were a whole range of divergent
jewish sex so it seems entirely possible
that there were a range of
savior cults running around at the same
time as paul using
similar terminology let's just keep in
mind that
both jesus and messiah both mean savior
what's the name of your savior uh we
just call him the savior
so jesus yeah yeah jesus
what's the name of your savior we just
call him the savior
so jesus yeah yeah jesus
each cult probably would have had their
favorite
messiah stories their favorite miracles
and their
favorite teachings each of course would
have had
their own missionaries as well there are
manifest signs in the new testament are
big differences and when you look at
other stuff that didn't get into the new
testament
it becomes real obvious at one point
paul gets
so angry about these competing
missionaries
that he writes in his letters he wishes
they would cut their own genitals off
as for those agitators i wish they would
go the whole way and emasculate
themselves
galatians 5 12. emasculate
means removal of the penis and the
testicles
not just castration but the whole
package so much for turning the other
cheek
and remember this is the same guy that
was beating up and arresting christians
just
20 years earlier forget about what the
disciples would have thought about him
for a second what would jesus have
thought about
paul as a torah observant jew i suspect
that he may have found
some of paul's rhetoric a little bit
heretical
i think that if jesus had said nobody
has to follow the jewish law anymore
then why would paul have had such a hard
time convincing jesus as apostles of
this
the gospels record certain missionary
instructions that jesus gave his
followers
but they're not detailed toward going to
the gentiles
which if you ask me is a little bit of
an oversight on jesus's behalf
all versions of christianity today uh
are basically descendants of paul's
version of christianity and that was
just one sec
now paul's not going after the
well-educated the gentiles or the the
rich and the famous
paul's going to take it down market it
becomes a religion for the
the poor and the downtrodden and the
oppressed
and the underprivileged who can all find
in this
a sense of a better tomorrow the graco
roman religions
didn't really offer much in the way of
an afterlife unless you were some sort
of great hero or
king and heaven doesn't actually turn up
in judaism much either
barely gets a mention in the old
testament but paul is saying
you can get eternity in paradise and
he's offering it to everyone
and who doesn't want to spend eternity
in paradise hell i'd be happy with a
weekend in paradise
so paul talks a lot about what jesus is
going to do when he comes
back but how much does he have to say
about the life
and teachings of jesus during his actual
time on earth
paul wrote a lot he wrote a massive
chunk
of the new testament and we don't even
get incidental mentions
not even once about miracles
jesus did healings it's absurd now one
of the explanations for this might be
that
paul's letter's really dealing with
disputes in his communities about
how to be good christians but isn't that
the perfect time to be quoting the
founder of the firm
when it comes to disputes about that he
could have easily
he could easily said jesus said this
when jesus was in jerusalem he said that
no what we get is paul speaking from his
own authority
he gets his information directly from
the lord
above from his celestial christ
and also from the earlier scriptures
paul briefly mentions that jesus was
born
died and resurrected in some form but
that's pretty much it when it comes to
talking about the life and teachings of
jesus
there are a few passages where he says
he got something from the lord but
as he claims no human told him anything
he might just be referring to the ghost
of jesus
to the married i give this command not i
but the lord
a wife must not separate from her
husband first corinthians
7 10 but paul has zero to say about the
miracles that jesus did in his lifetime
there's no turning water into wine no
multiplying loaves and fishes there's no
walking on water
there's no healing to sick with this
spit there's no exorcisms there's no
bringing people back from the dead
which is kind of strange if you think
about it if you knew somebody who could
do all of those things
you'd never stop talking about it
whether that's really strange or whether
that's
because for example he takes for granted
that they know
that already is hard to be sure
maybe paul assumed that they already
knew the stories
but we have to remember that paul's
writing his letters
20 to 30 years before the gospels were
written
maybe he'd never heard the stories maybe
he had
heard them but didn't believe them maybe
they were invented later
or maybe paul had heard the stories but
just didn't think they were very
important maybe he thought they were
completely irrelevant look at what
christian preachers do today
when they want to say what you should be
doing what you should be thinking what
you should behaving
what do they say they say jesus says
this jesus says this
jesus did this jesus taught that so why
doesn't paul
why does paul never say what would jesus
do what did matter to paul
was converting as many people as
possible as quickly as possible
because he's absolutely convinced that
time is running out
paul believes that the end of the world
is dawning any minute i mean every day
he gets up in the morning he thinks it
could be today
then we who are alive who are left shall
be caught up together with them
in the clouds to meet the lord in the
air
first thessalonians 4 17. but then
time goes on and the end still hasn't
arrived yet
so paul like every doomsday prophet
starts to hedge his bets a little
suddenly now we've got christians dying
and that's
not supposed to happen jesus is meant to
return
this kingdom of god is meant to be
ushered in and it's
not happening so there needs to be a
rethink well he says oh geez right
about the resurrection uh you see yeah
some are gonna die but uh but
christ will come back and the the dead
in christ will rise
first uh we'll have the we'll be second
in line
will be transformed paul was clearly
wrong
the the end didn't come paul eventually
realizes
that he's more likely than not going to
die before jesus returns
paul claims the ghost of jesus told him
the end of the world would come within
his lifetime
you'd think if god told you the end of
the world was happening
soon you'd be pretty careful about
getting confirmation
blessed are the meek turn the other
cheek
the world will end in your lifetime let
him who hath not sin
excuse me there there lord could you
just repeat that last bit
i'm not sure i heard you correctly the
words going on in my lifetime
yeah yeah in your lifetime are you sure
i find your lack of faith disturbing
hey hey okay chill big guy i just hate
to get something like that
wrong wouldn't want that of my
conscience
so as far as i can tell one of five
things must have happened
either one jesus made a mistake
two jesus lied three
jesus changed his mind and just forgot
to tell paul
four paul misunderstood jesus
or five paul just made it all up
this is a debate among historical jesus
scholars about whether
jesus believed that the end of the world
would happen in his lifetime
uh or not the vast vast majority of
scholars who say
no looks pretty clear from from jesus's
teachings as preserved in the gospels
that he really does expect the end to
come in his lifetime
so um he seems to have been
like many people before him and pretty
much everybody after him
everybody who's predicted that the world
was going to end in their lifetime
thus far has been wrong and jesus would
seem to have been one of those
now if you don't like to think of jesus
as getting something that important
wrong let's go with paul made it all up
and if he did maybe he's lying about all
this other stuff we're using him for
did he really meet peter and james we
only have his word for it
did the ghost of jesus really appear to
him and tell him to preach to the
gentiles so if paul is throwing out all
of this jewish law and tradition
telling people that the end is nigh and
having public arguments with the
original
apostles why did they tolerate him
well from how it appears in the bible it
seems that
james and paul agreed to some kind of
payment there's a lot of references and
letters to him collecting money from his
churches
it's clear that some of these churches
are challenging him like what are you
doing with this money and he has to like
justify that you know no no don't worry
i'm not running off with it i'm
doing what i said i was gonna do with it
which is he says taking it back to the
saints in jerusalem you know the holy
ones in jerusalem
uh and we're not entirely sure what that
means but you can be sure it certainly
meant that the jerusalem church these
heads are getting a cut
whether we want to call that a bribe
in terms of let's collect this money so
that the jerusalem christians don't send
missionaries
to make our lives more difficult it's
hard to say
and paul's not even sure that in romans
he's not even sure that they're going to
accept
this collection he says he expresses
anxiety
about taking this back to jerusalem
because he thinks well maybe they'll
reject it so that sounds a bit like a
bribe
and in fact it's he probably gets
arrested yeah
yeah yeah i mean you know if we follow
the book of acts
at that point what seems to be going on
when he is in jerusalem and is arrested
is that that's when he was going to take
the collection
back and put it at the feet of the
apostles
in jerusalem that doesn't seem to have
worked out
paul uh went to rome
and was under house arrest there so
presumably paul got
executed by the romans acts of the
apostles
written many decades later vaguely
blames paul's arrest in jerusalem on
some jews who complained that paul was
leading people astray
fellow israelites help us this is the
man who teaches
everyone everywhere against our people
and our law
and this place of course the people he's
taking the money to in jerusalem
also fit that description they are jews
who think that paul is leading people
astray with his idolatrous teachings
about abandoning the law
really in many ways i think we can say
that paul's the guy that invented
christianity as we know it today
if it wasn't for paul i think most
christians today
would probably be jews
[Music]
somewhere between the years of 60 and 70
ce
it's assumed that peter paul and james
all died we don't really know much about
where or when
or how it happened one thing we do know
happened during this period though is
some
jewish zealots decided to rise up
against roman occupation
and it led to a devastating war we don't
know
who started it could have been the
judean people's front could have been
the people's front of judea
we know it lasted for four years and the
jews got completely destroyed
as it turns out yahweh didn't send a
messiah
to save them as punishment for the
rebellion the romans
completely destroyed the temple in
jerusalem
something else happened just after the
destruction of the temple
the first christian gospel was written
the illicit of the gospels is probably
the gospel of mark which seems to be
written
about 70 a.d maybe a few years before
maybe a few years after
ironically the first thing i run into
again and again as i travel north
america and talk to people
uh who who either were christians or are
christians and they often tell me like
the first is like they were shocked to
find out that mark was written before
matthew
they were shocked to find out that the
letters of paul were written before the
gospels
here's something that might shock some
christians most scholars don't think
mark was written by an eyewitness
or even somebody who knew an eyewitness
the
tradition in
the 2nd century is that mark was written
by a disciple of the apostle peter
and that he was sort of peter's
secretary who followed him around
and took peter's sermon notes and
arranged them into
sort of a narrative about jesus
is that who mark really was it's hard to
say
if mark had been peter's scribe mark
would say i'm peter scribe that's how
ancient historiography was written
and despite it being called the gospel
according to mark
the document doesn't actually state who
the author was
the difficulty with mark's gospel is
it's like
the other gospels it's anonymous we
don't really know where it comes from
most people now think that it's unlikely
that mark is kind of taking down
peter's dictation or anything like that
but for the sake of simplicity
let's refer to him as mark otherwise
we're going to end up in prince
territory you know the
author formerly known as mark and how's
mark's gospel connected to the jewish
roman war
mark is kind of obsessed with the temple
as if something recent and traumatic has
happened so it makes a lot of sense to
say that mark's written after the fall
of the temple in
a.d 70. the romans had just come in and
destroyed
the temple just ended the cult basically
raised the city
city of god destroyed god's temple so
this is a big existential issue if
you're a sect
that stems from the jews and the jewish
god just let
heathens come in and destroy his own
house this is a problem
this is a marketing problem right it's a
pr problem so how do you explain that
well mark a lot of mark is structured
to answer that and say like well here's
the answer they've got to
reinvent themselves according to the
jewish historian josephus who
actually fought in the war over a
million jews
died this is a profoundly traumatic time
for judaism they've lost the land
they've lost the temple they've lost the
sense of god's
blessing on their everyday lives so so
this is really a very difficult time
indeed for
jews and of course the original jesus
gang the disciples
were jews living in jerusalem so they
probably got swept up in all of the
death and destruction too what happened
to them
we don't really know there's no
historical record
in fact we have nothing at all written
down by
peter or james or any other eyewitness
of jesus
nothing zero nada zip bapkus
oh yeah sure there are letters in the
new testament that claimed to be written
by them but do scholars believe those
letters are actually legit
i don't think we actually have any
extant writings
from peter or from james we have
documents that claim to be by them
they're probably other people
writing in their honor in their name
pretending to be these figures so
we are actually a little bit
weak on knowing what peter and james
actually
thought we have to reconstruct what they
thought like half of the letters
attributed to paul that found their way
into the new testament many scholars
believe the letters from peter and
james are fake that means we really
don't have any clear idea of what
jesus's immediate disciples actually
thought about him
his teachings his miracles what he told
them in private
or what they thought about paul they
must have been writing letters
too but apparently nobody bothered to
keep copies of them
it's all erased uh that that data had to
have existed it had to have been written
down somewhere in some form
it's just all gone well how convenient
for team paul
after the jewish roman war they're the
only major christian
sect that's left these are the gentiles
the
greeks and romans who aren't jews don't
understand judaism
and quite frankly don't like the jews
who kind of made fun of their version of
the messiah
so the original disciples the people who
actually knew
jesus and their movement is pretty much
completely wiped out
within 40 years of the death of jesus
christ
and if we accept that most of the new
testament writing occurs
post 70 when the jews
have been removed as an influence
then the kind of poor line crusade from
20 years earlier
is going to win so mark's gospel is
written for a gentile
community not jews and probably in rome
sometime just after the reign of the
emperor nero and there's a lot of
strange stuff in mark's gospel
one of them is that jesus is walking
around trying to tell his disciples to
keep their mouth shut
about the miracles that he's doing like
it's supposed to be some kind of big
secret
mark starts out his gospel with saying
something that it just blows my mind
and that's in mark 4 11 where he has
jesus gather all his disciples and say
okay i'm teaching you all these things
in secret
in parables that way you'll know what
i'm talking about
but those outsiders they won't be able
to tell what i'm talking about
otherwise and this is the kicker they
would turn from their sins
and repent and be saved and he told them
the mystery of the kingdom of god has
been given to you
but to those on the outside everything
is expressed in parable
so that they may be ever seen but never
perceiving
and ever hearing but never understanding
otherwise
they might turn and be forgiven mark 4
11
they can't handle the truth what kind of
messiah
tells his disciples to keep his work a
big secret
what kind of messiah doesn't want his
disciples
to be forgiven according to mark jesus
is telling
secret teachings only to his inner
circle
and when you ask a biblical scholar
today well what are those secret
teachings he was giving
they don't know any more than we do
those secret teachings are lost forever
like the truth about who killed jfk and
what happened to michael jackson's nose
maybe the whole secrecy business
is mark's way of explaining why most
people in his
time had never heard of jesus this is
all made up by the gospel the author of
the gospel of mark
as sort of damage control and
explanation
for why people didn't widely accept
him as the messiah because he didn't
want them to so around mark's time
people are saying
he did all these miracles i never heard
of any guy doing miracles he goes well
that's because he told us not to tell
anyone
right exactly maybe this story about
parables is also a parable
you you go through the gospel story
after story after story and they look
like parables that has
you know additional meanings like they
might not be meant to be taken
historically true
uh and this is how mythology is written
right you tell a story about something
and it's the meaning of the story rather
than the literal truth of the story
that's
actually the important part of the story
for instance let's take a look at the
story of the
trial of jesus and mark tells this story
where
uh pontius pilate wants to let jesus go
uh
but mark says that this was the holiday
and on the holiday the romans would
traditionally let go one prisoner
uh and the crowd kept calling for
barabbas we want to release barabbas
whom mark says was a notorious rebel
a rebel and murderer right and pilots
like no no let me let jesus go
and not this this murders rebel and no
there's no let release barabbas release
barabbas and so pilate lets him go
and then jesus is crucified and that's
the story
when we look at the depiction of pilate
in non-biblical sources
pilate is venal pilate does not care at
all about jewish sensibilities
pilate goes out of his way to offend
jews pilate
is awful but when we look at the gospels
going from the earlier gospel like mark
up to john
pilate looks better and better and
better he
i would date pilate from the gospels
because he seems like a perfectly decent
guy
who simply backed into the corner by a
bunch of evil jewish
leaders who want him to do away with
jesus now there's no way this is
historically true
so what does barabbas translate as
son of rabbas the word bar in aramaic
means son of
and abbas comes from abba which means
father
and he is the best bit and according to
the gospel of matthew barabbas's first
name
was jesus jesus barabbas jesus son of
the father
pilate says you can have jesus barabbas
a murderer
and insurrectionist or you can have
jesus of nazareth
the other jesus son of the father the
jews are given a choice between
two jesus's two saviors one
is the violent kind of savior like the
one who tried to
overthrow the romans in the rebellion of
66
ce the other is a pacifist kind of
savior who's never hurt
anything which one will the jews choose
to punish and what happens
the innocent jesus pays the penalty pays
the ransom
for the very guilty barabbas son of the
father
in terms of christian theology it's
perfect in terms of history it's
ridiculous
two identical saviors one is going to be
set free
one is going to pay the penalty now if
you're a jew living in the first century
this story might sound a little familiar
well we know this story this is in
leviticus this is the whole ritual of
yom kippur which is the whole atonement
ceremony
yom kippur is usually expressed in
english as
day of atonement there were two great
ceremonies in the jewish calendar one
was passover and the other was
yom kippur and this one every year there
would be this you have the two goats the
two identical goats they have to be you
know look the same
one you would cast the sins of israel on
and cast it into the crowd
release it into the wilderness and the
other you would sacrifice on the altar
in the temple and its blood would atone
for all the sins of israel
the barabbas story seems to be saying
that the goat
sacrifices which had replaced human
sacrifices in judaism
are now being replaced once more with
the
ultimate human sacrifice mark is writing
for one of
paul's communities possibly in rome
originally it was written to symbolize
the gospel
it wasn't written to be taken as
literally true at least not by informed
insiders in the sect
this story by the way is where we get
the term scapegoat
forgive me lord i have committed murder
that's a terrible sin have you pushed a
goat
well yes lord i did
[Music]
now most people who read the barabba
story today probably aren't jews
probably don't know their leviticus very
well so the whole story about two
identical goats
goes right over their heads
and i think you can go from story to
story through mark and see like if you
look at it as history it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense
but if you look at it as allegory as as
something representing something else
then it makes perfect sense and looks
literally brilliant then towards the end
of mark's gospel
we find jesus in the garden of
gethsemane
where he's literally begging yahweh not
to let him
be killed they went to a place called
gethsemane
he began to be deeply distressed and
troubled
he fell to the ground and prayed that if
possible the hour might pass from him
father
take this cup from me mark 14
32 to 42
it's a very moving story
until you realize that jesus
is yahweh so this was his own plan all
along and
he's literally begging himself not to
kill himself which is
pretty confusing in mark jesus
appears to be very human he doesn't talk
or
act like a god in disguise this might be
an idea that
christians came up with later speaking
of
humans and parables one of the stories
that we don't find in mark
is the virgin birth mark starts his
gospel
and says the beginning of the gospel of
jesus christ the son of god
and then he doesn't tell us a story
about jesus birth
but instead narrates jesus's baptism by
john
and if you look carefully at this
story with the holy spirit descending
upon jesus like a dove and god saying
this is my beloved son
it sort of sounds like mark is saying
that this is when jesus becomes the son
of god at his baptism
in ancient rome birds landing on things
was read as a positive sign from the
gods
the process of deciphering the movement
of the birds was called
taking the auspices which literally
translates as
looking at birds it's the basis by the
way of the english word auspicious
now the person who took the auspices was
known as an
auger which is the basis of the name
augustus the original son of god
so again many people living in the roman
empire 1900 years ago
reading mark would probably have
understood the symbolism
so what you see in early christian
history
is that the status of jesus is son of
god keeps getting kicked back farther
and farther
first it's the resurrection then it's at
his baptism
then it's at his birth then he's always
been there from the beginning of time
so it evolved the idea of jesus evolved
over
a century or so yes definitely and
that's just for paul's communities
the other factions including the one of
the original disciples had different
ideas altogether
in fact as we'll see a little bit later
on at least one
major early christian faction didn't
even believe
jesus was divine at all one of the other
surprising things
that's missing from mark's gospel is one
of the most important ideas in all of
christianity
jesus's resurrection appearances to his
followers
it's so odd the oldest gospel is mark's
gospel
most scholars believe that i believe
that and
there are no appearances of the risen
jesus to his disciples in fact the
gospel ends in a very
dark and quite mysterious enigmatic way
where
this young man who just happens to be at
the tomb says to the women
you know go and tell the disciples and
peter what's happened to these women
and the women just run away and and
don't tell anyone for they're afraid
that's it
so i mean if you believe mark's gospel
no one ever found out
about the resurrection because they
didn't tell anybody including mark who
right
couldn't have written it down because
yeah it's extraordinary
at some point a christian scribe decided
to write a new ending to mark's gospel
he decided to sex it up a little bit
he retconned it like george lucas making
greedo shoot first
i have to wonder why bother why not just
leave the original ending as it was
what's happening i think is that the
secret doctrines some of the secret
teachings are leaking out
into the public teachings the first rule
about jesus club
is you don't talk about jesus club these
particular doctrines became less
important to keep secret
and so you see them leaking out over
time so you get uh
you know this the nativity idea or you
get the you know the magical incarnation
idea
more of the secrets are being leaked out
and more attempt to try and
prove points by creating stories that
support your points
and so you get more miracle stories you
get more uh
doctrinally relevant stuff it really
makes me wonder about the intentions
of these early christians if the truth
was so important to them
why bother rewriting the ending of the
first gospel
and just like paul mark is counting down
mark's gospel believes just like paul
does that the
end is absolutely imminent so there is a
line in mark's gospel
some of those standing here jesus says
will not taste death
before they see the kingdom of god come
with power it's it's one of these
interesting ironies of history that
every time there's a delay
in the eschaton coming the faithful
don't kind of give up
on the idea they become all the more
eager in thinking that it's about to
happen the eschaton means the end times
the end of the world as we know it
like a modern ufo cult yeah so
modern religious cults as well i mean
they do this all the time when
disappointment comes they don't say oh
we must
have been wrong or at least they don't
say we must have been wrong
in our fundamental identity they just we
may got the timetable a bit wrong so
you revise it you change it and the
early christians were no different from
that
those christians who believe that the
bible is literally true
must have a hard time explaining why the
world hasn't ended yet
it's one of the things that i think many
christians across the centuries have
really struggled with the fact that
jesus appears to say
that he is coming back within the
lifetime of his followers and that
clearly didn't happen
it clearly didn't happen you can
spiritualize it you can kind of try and
find some sort of fine
fancy way of saying in a very real sense
spiritually he did come but
the fact is that he didn't return in the
lifetime of his
of his followers as he had said that he
would and this is something that has
always been at the heart of some real
anxiety in christianity it's almost like
a kind of a trauma trying to come to
terms with how
can it be that jesus said this when it
didn't actually happen yeah definitely
you can see a trajectory in the new
testament writings as you move
from letters like paul's so the earliest
writings we have to writings composed
in the you know first half of the second
century
where the apocalyptic expectations just
continue to get sort of toned down and
there becomes sort of an increasing
recognition that jesus is not
coming back anytime soon each generation
of christians was probably led to
believe that it would happen in their
time
just like still happens and they may not
even have noticed that there had been a
delay it's not like most people had
copies of the bible to read
so they only knew what they heard in
church don't worry though
the end of the world is coming any
day now
[Music]
the next gospel to be written was
matthew probably
10 or 20 years after mark around 80 or
90
ce so who was he gospel of matthew
is attributed to matthew one of the
twelve disciples
but it's it's improbable that this was
actually written
by an eyewitness because
matthew's gospel is using as one of its
major sources
mark and if mark is not written by a
disciple event
why would a disciple an eyewitness to
jesus's ministry
use somebody else's second-hand reports
why wouldn't they just tell their own
story so
so it does not seem that matthew is
actually written by an eyewitness
and also matthew again is writing in
greek matthew is written
i think by a jewish christian who
he kind of likes mark's gospel he copies
whole passages
verbatim you know so he clearly quite
likes mark's gospel
but i think he thinks mark got some
things wrong for mark
who's firmly in paul's world of
christian gentiles
jesus doesn't appear to be very jewish
matthew on the other hand calls
bs and all of that in matthew jesus is
quite
clear that he's only interested in the
jews
i was sent only to the lost sheep of the
house of israel
it is not right to take the children's
bread and throw it to the dogs
matthew 15 24-26 these 12
jesus sent out with the following
instructions do not go among the
gentiles or enter any town of the
samaritans
go rather to the lost sheep of israel
matthew 10
5-6 which makes paul's claims that the
ghost of jesus
told him to go and preach to the
gentiles pretty suspect
i mean if that was jesus's original
intention
he think he would have told his apostles
so matthew was engaged in this
fascinating project of
re-judaizing jesus and quite
interestingly because jesus was a jew
and because he was probably
quite faithful to the law matthew went
away is also re-jesusizing mark's gospel
is actually
bringing it a bit back around to what
jesus was probably more like the
historical jesus that is
a jew yeah preaching to jews about being
a good jew
right it is an irony of history that
the most popular gospel in christian
history far and away has been the gospel
of matthew and yet it presents
the most jewish uh
you know of the four gospels and
probably would have been quite hostile
to the kind of law free christianity
that paul is proposing these two sources
paul and the gospel of matthew would
definitely
come into conflict over whether uh
gentile christians should follow the law
paul
definitely says no they don't matthew
says yes
absolutely they do and it's one of the
amazing things about christianity is
that most people just ignore
that most people just ignore it but it
was a very important strand in early
christianity in emerging christianity
that saw the christians duty
as being not just to be loyal to jesus
but also to be loyal to the jewish law
and they and they were loyal to the law
because they believe that's what jesus
had taught them to do
so matthew's position is if you're not
going to temple
you're not circumcised and you're not
eating kosher food
you're doing jesus wrong that's right
they have to get well at the very least
they have to get a
copy of the talmud and start learning
hebrew
where yamako yep the matthew gospel is
where some of those most
famous and dubious jesus stories
first turn up remember how in paul's day
there seemed to be
lots of factions telling different
stories about jesus
matthew seems to have included stories
he had heard
that mark either hadn't heard or just
didn't like
stories like the sermon on the mount the
resurrection appearances
and the massacre of the innocents where
herod the great
king of judea orders the execution of
all male babies around bethlehem
historians by the way have found no
other evidence of that
ever happening matthew probably just
made it up to sound like the similar
story about
moses in the old testament matthew is
also the first person to mention
the virgin birth so fully half a century
appears
before we ever get anyone writing about
a virgin birth the story of the virgin
birth i i think is
is baffling you have in matthew's gospel
this
genealogy that connects jesus
right back to abraham going through
david king david the possibly mythical
second king
of the united kingdom of israel and
judah who supposedly killed a giant with
a slingshot
all going through joseph jesus father
then the very next story is about how
joseph isn't jesus's father i mean
religious people are very good at
getting their head around contradictions
but there's a big one right there on the
very first page of the new testament
it's fascinating what did matthew think
he was doing
why is he telling a story about a
virginal conception when he also wants
to tell us that jesus was descended
from david via his father i don't know i
think it's i think it's a mystery
did he just hope no one would notice and
so
jesus is the descendant of king david
because joseph is his father
but i thought mary was a virgin yeah
look over there it's the messiah
where oh no it's just larry they got the
same beard
oh no no i lost my place hey don't worry
about it
let's go get a kosher kebab and the fact
is lots of people don't notice
many christians will happily affirm
jesus is the son of david
they will also affirm that jesus was
conceived by a virgin
scholars believe that matthew's idea of
a virgin
birth is possibly based on a bad
translation of the old testament
see in the hebrew version of the prophet
isaiah he predicts that
a baby boy will be born as a sign that
god is going to destroy his enemies
and the hebrew word that isaiah uses to
describe the
mother of the boy is alma now alma just
translates as a
childless young woman but matthew wasn't
using the hebrew version of
isaiah he was using a greek translation
which mistranslated alma into
virgin another unfortunate thing about
matthew's gospel
is despite it being fairly pro-torah
it's also inspired 1900 years
of anti-semitism in matthew's gospel
you have this ideal of a kind of
loyalty to torah loyalty to the
synagogue to
all of these jewish traditions and yet
also
this bitter bitter vitriol
against fellow jews now keep in mind
that although matthew
is a jew and he's writing for a
community of jewish christians
they're an extremely fringe sect kind of
like the way that
catholics view mormons today and he's
riding
10 or 20 years after this big jewish
roman war
so jews are probably pretty unpopular
across the empire
and the jesus jews want to distance
themselves from the traditional jews as
much as possible
for political reasons and matthew just
like
mark and paul before him believes that
the end of the world
is going to happen very soon
but keep in mind by the time he's riding
most of those original disciples are
probably dead
and yet there's still no sign of jesus
[Music]
according to most scholars the next
gospel to be written is luke
written somewhere between 10 and 30
years
after matthew luke by the way also wrote
the acts of the apostles which is kind
of
a sequel to the gospels luke's writing i
think this you know really big
epic narrative he wants to tell the
story of jesus and the story of
the early church luke uh according to
tradition
uh was a traveling companion of paul he
was a gentile
a physician you know a doctor in the
ancient world so he was definitely a
what we would call a second generation
christian he says this is the stuff that
was handed on to us
uh and written down by earlier
generations and i'm
you know working with it myself in
reality we know he's not
using oral lore we know he's using the
previous books
uh mark and matthew so yeah so the
traditional attributions are clearly
late legend and mainstream scholarship
has long since realized that and gotten
off that wagon
acts of the apostles luke's account of
what happened after jesus died
tries to whitewash all of this
tension and conflict that obviously
existed between paul and the original
jesus gang luke undeadly is trying to
present an idealized account
of the early christian community
certainly at the end of acts chapter 2
you've got everyone gathered around the
apostles teaching breaking bread
worshiping god finding favor of god and
all the people so it's definitely an
idealized
account all of the anger tension and
bribery that we see in paul's letters
either disappears in luke or
gets toned down it's kind of like he's
saying
oh it was nowhere near as bad as you've
probably heard
so he i think he does try to paint
generally
a rosy picture of it but it's it's
certainly
not a complete whitewash he does include
some instant instances of division and
differences
and i mean he does portray paul as quite
a hot head by the time
luke's writing acts towards the end of
the first century
the poor line community are trying to
strengthen
their credentials trying to solidify
their connection
to the original founders peter and james
who are probably dead at this stage
their community is pretty much wiped out
and so they can't
fight back winners get to write
the history all in all luke's not a very
credible historical source
and luke just like matthew mark and paul
before him
believes the end of the world is going
to happen anytime soon
truly i tell you this generation will
not pass away until all these things are
fulfilled
luke 21 32
[Music]
the last of the four gospels to be
written is john
probably written around 100 or 110
ce compared to the other three
john is different think of it this way
the synoptic gospels
the gospels of mark matthew and luke are
called synoptic which means they share a
common vision of jesus
uh new york la chicago
john is basically new orleans
okay he's just he's doing something very
different down there
with john this whole thing is so
obviously a literary creation
jesus in the gospel of john does not
sound like he does in the other gospels
and all the characters in john sound the
same way like you're watching a woody
allen movie everybody's talking like
woody allen in it because he wrote
everybody's part
and and so uh you've it's obvious
this is not anybody's recollection
instead of telling everyone to keep the
stories about his miracles a big secret
he might as well have on a t-shirt i am
god written in big letters
and you have to wonder well didn't they
have blasphemy laws then why
wasn't he stoned to death five minutes
out of the gate the woman saith unto him
i know that messiah cometh he that is
called christ
when he has come he will declare unto us
all things
jesus saith unto her i that speak unto
thee
am he john 4 25
i am my father are one john 10 30.
john's gospel contains no parables
no last supper no sermon on the mount
but it's the only one with jesus raising
lazarus from the dead
and it's the most anti-semitic of the
gospels
as for the second coming as far as
john's concerned
it's happening right now
why is john so different from the other
three gospels
no one really knows but if we look at
paul and the four gospels in
chronological order we can kind of see
how the
jesus story evolved over time in
paul he doesn't do any miracles and
becomes special
after he died in mark he becomes special
when a bird lands on him
walks around being a secret miracle
worker whose body disappears from a cave
matthew and luke make him the product of
a divine pregnancy
who comes back from the dead and in john
he's proudly out of the god closet
but if you think the variation in these
stories are strange
why do you see the stories that didn't
even make it into the bible
[Music]
so one of the things that many
christians
don't know is that in addition to the
four canonical gospels
there's a number of other early
christian
gospels out there canonical means
approved by the vatican
in the early centuries there were some
fairly significant christian
factions the ebionites the martianites
and the gnostics
and they all had pretty different ideas
about
who jesus was their gospels were all
destroyed
by imperial decree around 400 ce
however one suspects that some
monk in upper egypt decided i i can't
do this to you know i've i've spent my
entire life riding them out for example
i can't do this to that so i'm going to
gather them up and put them away safely
and say that they're destroyed whatever
but the wonderful thing that happened in
1945 is there was the discovery of
12 codices 12 ancient leather books
found in a jar in nagamadi in egypt
some of them and the ones that i love
the most
are infancy gospels so stories about
jesus's
birth and childhood and one of the most
interesting of these
is a text that is generally known as the
infancy gospel of thomas
and what this text seeks to do is say
what would jesus have been like as a
child
if he's a divine being which this text
believes him to be if he's a divine
being from the beginning
he's got all this miraculous power what
does he actually
what does a kid like that look like
according to the infancy gospel of
thomas it's not a pretty picture
it's jesus the bart simpson of the kind
of the early christian world he's really
a brat
one story in the infancy gospel of
thomas says that when jesus was
five years old he was sitting by a pool
of water making clay
sparrows which were coming to life and
when another kid came and
messed with his pool of water jesus
cursed him
and he withered up and died
he's basically a little super villain
yeah i'd say so
because he essentially gets angry at a
number of his playmates for different
things
and kills them and so he kills one
playmate
he kills another playmate then the
villagers start to complain to mary and
joseph
what's kid jesus's response to all this
he makes his accusers go blind
[Music]
this ron burgundy says that escalated
rather quickly
uh so it's it's a it's a fascinating
story and yet if we think
that the story is saying oh jesus had
these sort of you know immature things
that he had to work out of his system
i don't think that's what the infancy
gospel of thomas is saying
it's essentially saying that's who jesus
is he's got all the power of god
and if people are jerks to him
he can you know he can strike them dead
this
is how they viewed jesus weird and
upsetting to us as it seems to be
and i love i love joseph's instructions
to mary after all of this has happened
he takes jesus puts him in their house
and tells mary
don't let him outside because those who
annoy him end up dead
oh you might think well that's an
unbelievable story no wonder it didn't
end up in the bible
but is it any crazier than stories about
walking on
water or turning water into wine or
raising people from the dead or zapping
demons into a herd of pigs why do we say
these magic stories are crazy but these
other
stories about magic well they're just
fine and dandy back then they were
arguing over
what jesus was who he was what was his
relationship to god all the
controversies about christology
and this included of course whether
jesus was even
a human being just a really interesting
human being who somehow
became possessed by god others thought
he was an
angel still others thought he was part
of god
still others thought he was just a good
teacher they didn't know one of the
really big
early christian factions the ebionites
might have closely resembled the
original christians
team peter the ebianites again that
means the poor
they claim to be the descendants of the
jerusalem christians
maybe they were to be a true christian
you had to
obey the jewish law they seemed to have
denied the idea of the virgin birth
and they had a kind of gospel that
sounds
very much like a jewish christian
gospel may be one of the earliest forms
of the gospel we have people who are
following jewish law
honoring the sabbath on saturday and
keeping it holy circumcising their kids
and their worshiping jesus the ebionites
declared paul
a heretic on the other hand another one
of the major early factions the
martianites
loved paul but really hated judaism
marcion said that that jesus
had come from a different god not the
hebrew god not the creator god not the
torah giving god the god of the old
testament
so the god of the old testament was was
a a
wicked god who made the world i mean
that's why the world was so messed up
the gnostics
claimed to have a special teaching from
jesus that only
they knew about well the word gnostic
really means somebody who's claiming to
have knowledge but it's basically the
idea
that this this world is bad and wicked
and we have to get away from it and
getting a certain secret knowledge of
the universe's origins
and your own cosmic origins is how you
get away from it all
so why didn't all of those gospels make
it into the bible well a common
christian view is that the ones that
made it in with the real stories
and the ones that didn't were just made
up
well when it comes to the stories of
jesus's birth
and childhood it's all made up if you
talk to uh most new testament scholars
about the infancy narratives the
christmas story in matthew's gospel and
luke's gospel
they'll say there's not much historical
basis behind
any of that there's no census there's no
slaughter of the innocence by herod
there's no star of bethlehem no wise men
jesus probably was not born in bethlehem
he was probably born
in nazareth those stories are all
propaganda that are designed on the one
hand
to present jesus as a divine being from
the moment of his birth
and also to say he can fit the
qualifications for messiah
because he's born in the city of david
of course all of these factions believe
that
their version of christianity was the
correct one
just like they all do today there are
many different
christianities today there were many
different christianities
back then
[Music]
eventually team paul sold their soul to
the first
christian emperor constantine who fought
his way to power in the year
305 ce according to his contemporary
bishop eusebius the so-called father of
church history jesus appeared to
constantine
in a vision and said he'd help him
defeat his
rival for the throne in a bloody war
hallelujah jesus is finally the warrior
king messiah
that the jews had been waiting for
according to christian sources from the
time
jesus used his supernatural powers to
help
constantine kill thousands of roman
citizens
and consolidate his control over the
empire
winners are grinners and so because
the the a version of christianity
secures imperial support early in the
fourth century
they're able to suppress their opponents
ever more effectively
once christianity um and you know
orthodox christian became the official
religion of the empire they had official
patronage um yeah
you then could use imperial power to
put the thumb screws down on any
dissident christian groups
the final selection of books that made
it into the bible wasn't actually
decided upon
until 400 ce it seems like a number of
competing christian factions might have
merged into some sort of mega church
each of these gospels has a faction
behind it there's a lot of people
like they have their own favorite gospel
it's like everybody has their own
favorite harry potter novel or whatever
and so if you want to win this battle
for control of the church you want as
many people on your side to outnumber
the other
side and the best way to do that is to
pick gospels that had a lot of
supporters behind them
that were not too deviant the other
gospels were declared
fake news constantine does not enforce
christianity on everybody
constantine allowed pagan temples to
stand in pagans to worship and
he let jews be jews but he does favor
just one christian faction and tries to
shut down all the rest
and this one faction has no hesitation
at putting the head of the roman empire
the same roman empire that killed
jesus paul peter and james at the head
of their church
and so constantine i think he treats
christianity as any emperor has
treated any other religious kind of
group
by saying well i'm the head of religion
i'm the
i am the pontifex maximus so therefore
i'm the head of this
community um the bishop seemed to
agree to that without much hesitation
overnight the persecuted become the
persecute tours
and the first group that they persecute
are other christians who they now
declare
heretics you're only a heretic if you
lose the historical battle
and it takes the church about three to
four hundred years to figure out who's
in
and who's out about 50 years after
constantine
another roman emperor theodosius
drove the final nail into the cross and
made catholic christianity
the state religion of the empire so not
only are
pre-existing varieties or versions of
christianity wiped out or
put on a banned list new dissident
groups emerge and are dealt with
with this new kind of imperial authority
temples were shut down
pagan priests if they wanted to keep
their job became christian
priests jews had their movements
restricted
were not allowed to join certain guilds
had their synagogues burned down
and the empire becomes christian and it
remains christian because of the force
of the state
and the force of the army
was this a good thing or a bad thing it
was a thing
and it's something we have to deal with
to put a modern perspective on it
imagine that the scientologists were
able to get
tom cruise elected president of the
world and he
passed a law making scientology
mandatory and that's what team paul did
around about
400 ce the roman empire
became a theocracy not unlike the
caliphate that isis has been trying to
set up in the middle east in the last
few years
it's not that hard to be a successful
religion when you're the only game in
town and everything else is pretty much
outlawed so that's the story of how
christianity went from being
irrelevant to inescapable
but in the words of a different god wait
there's one more thing
[Music]
you know it wasn't that long ago that
most historians believe that the
characters in the old testament like
abraham or moses
or figures from literary history like
king arthur
were also based on real people
but today most historians think they are
completely mythical so
what about jesus well when i started as
a historian
and i was actually quite certain that
jesus existed as a historical person and
i thought anyone who suggested otherwise
was a crackpot
and what happened was the more i looked
at the evidence the worse it looked the
more you pull up the threads the more it
falls apart and i started to realize by
the end of it it was like
actually on balance of evidence it looks
like it goes the other way it just seems
to me
the the weight of probability is
that there was no jesus one thing that
struck me
is just the case for this figure is
extremely poor
the main sources we have are the gospels
over time we found even more reason to
doubt the gospels
they're just really really poor sources
they're not what we want
e.p sanders says that jesus is better
attested in history than alexander the
great
um when you when you actually compare
the evidence for both of those figures
that's not even close to correct and
actually the evidence for alexander the
great is
way better than for jesus obviously a
lot of evidence gets
lost or destroyed over the years like
the letters of team
peter so historians are trying to piece
together
what happened using sketchy evidence or
evidence that's been
corrupted like mark's gospel and the
trick to that
is that you look at that body of
evidence you gotta look at it all you
can't leave anything out even stuff
that's weird
and say is that the evidence that should
exist if this hypothesis existed is it
what we expect
uh and and that's what you look at and
you can measure that in the sense of
your feeling of like how expected is
this evidence or how
weird is this evidence given that
hypothesis and then you look at all of
the theories and try and decide
which one does the evidence support best
and if you're stuck in this situation
where the evidence is equally expected
on all your hypotheses
then you don't know it could be any one
of those hypotheses and we just kind of
have to settle on
well it's one of those we don't know so
how does the evidence stack up
with the theory that jesus actually
existed i think on balance he probably
didn't exist i think the
the hypothesis that he started out a
revelatory being and became historicized
later
i think fits the evidence better it
makes the evidence more expected
especially a lot of the weird stuff
so in other words jesus appeared as some
kind of an
angel in visions to people like paul
and then later on people decided that
well he must have been
real but of course this kind of a view
is still a minority
amongst scholars but will it always be
that way
we saw the same thing with the
challenging of the historicity of moses
right in the 70s
everybody said that's fringe that's
crazy now it's the mainstream consensus
at least agnosticism about the
historicity of moses uh and that took
you know
20 30 years so you know i i always tell
people like
come back to me in 20 and 30 years and
then we'll see if that's still the
situation or if it's changed since then
this kind of talk gets some people
pretty
pretty cranky well look my my blunt
response to that the whole jesus
mythicism thing
to be frank i consider it mental
masturbation for atheists
that's the best way i can describe it
it's the ultimate get off
telling your arch enemy that their
superhero didn't exist it's with the joy
of going up to some bratty kid you don't
like and saying hey kid guess what
there's no santa claus telling a little
kid that santa doesn't exist
might be mean but it's also true
look the fact is that the historical
evidence that jesus existed
is pretty slim to say the least
but the evidence that the stories about
him were all over the place
and kind of evolved over time is
incredibly strong
make from that what you will
[Music]
so let's take a look at what our new
updated sunday school
story looks like around 2000 years ago
the romans decided the dead men could be
gods and living men could be sons of
gods
meanwhile in the backwaters of the roman
empire the jewish people were waiting
for their god yahweh to send a warrior
king they called the messiah to kick out
the romans
but the messiah was a no-show eventually
several generations later a small fringe
jewish sex
said this is our guy jesus christ which
means saving the savior
was a very jewish jew but had two
problems in his messianic resume
he had not defeated the romans and he
was already dead
a few years later paul who had been busy
beating up early jesus worshipers
suddenly changed his mind and invented
his own version of the jesus sect
he reinvented the messiah to be a
super-powered celestial warrior king for
non-jews who could keep their foreskin
and still get into heaven
the og christians weren't impressed this
is fake news paul didn't even know
jesus this is a jews only club bubbler
according to paul
jesus spoke to him in visions and any
day now jc would come down to earth with
supernatural powers to defeat the romans
and anyone else who didn't worship him
unfortunately jesus didn't return within
paul's lifetime
and despite writing lots of letters in
his 30 years of missionary work
paul never mentioned anything about
jesus's life teachings or miracles
but the jews did get their war against
the romans and got their butts
badly kicked no warrior king messiah
showed up and their temple was torn down
the original disciples of jesus were all
dead leaving not a single written record
of what they thought about jesus or his
teachings
after the war one of paul's community
did document some stories about jesus in
which he appears as a human
but with superpowers and a big secret
who begs yahweh not to let him be killed
but yahweh
ignored his prayers many other versions
of the jesus story were recorded over
the next 100 years
none by actual eyewitnesses or people
who knew eyewitnesses or people or new
people who
you get the idea as time passed these
stories grew
more far-fetched suddenly including
miracles like walking on water the
virgin birth
the resurrection of violent teenage
jesus and jesus
raising people from the dead all these
authors were still certain that the
messiah would come to defeat their
enemies within their lifetimes but he
still didn't come
for 300 years various jesus factions
fought against the romans lines and
amongst themselves
about who jesus was and how to worship
him properly until one of these groups
met with the roman emperor and said
give us protection and tax breaks and
we'll make you the head of our religion
that's enough i can refuse said the
emperor constantine
and within a hundred years this group
managed to take control of the entire
empire they burnt competing gospels tore
down temples
killed pagan philosophers and banned
other religions including competing
versions of the jesus club
and that my friends is the slightly more
accurate story
of the triumph of christianity amen
well isn't that a far more interesting
story and it's also one that's supported
by
historical evidence and biblical
scholars
so what does the next century hold for
christianity
peace and love or another theocracy i
guess
only time is going to tell unless of
course jesus
does come back soon which i've been told
with
very good authority should be happening
any minute now
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
six feet two eyes of blue
jesus christ he wasn't you has
anybody seen my lord
big hook knows there he goes preaching
so that everyone knows has anybody
seen my lord speared in the abdomen
by a roman blood gushing out
roasting the dead so it is said people
believe without a doubt jesus died
still a jew still a jew so why aren't
you
has anybody seen my has
anybody seen my has anybody seen my lord
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]